peut-être que la nuance excusez moi
c'était un peu emmerdant et les gens qui
parlent sans nuance donne l'impression
d'avoir raison quelqu'un qui doute parce
que lannion savoir être le doute aussi
avec la certitude avec la prudence on
dit ce type là il sait pas ce qu'ils
pensent et donc un propos nuancés donne
l'impression de se fragiliser par la
forme qu'il prend et c'est ça qui me
semble être une menace parce que on sait
très bien que c'est pas dans les
positions les plus extrêmes qu'on trouve
la vérité mais dans des imbrications des
superpositions dans la nuance
précisément quel ce qu'elle se situe et
on pourrait bien dans certains médias
quelqu'un qui vient dire une énorme
bêtise à la télévision à la radio a
engendré tout un toute une série de
réactions beaucoup plus nombreuses que
quelqu'un qui dit quelque chose de
prud'hommes en dix ans qu'on c est ce qu
on ne sait pas en expliquer la
différence entre les deux et c'est
pourquoi l'être humain a autant de mal à
dire je ne sais pas eh bien je ne sais
pas non mais c'est une très bonne
question mais moi j'ai aucun mal à dire
je ne sais pas mais reconnaissez que si
à chaque fois que vous me posez une
question je vous répondais je ne sais
pas est ce que vous me réinvite riez moi
j'ai l'impression quand je regarde les
réseaux sociaux qu'en effet il faut
pro-choix zir son camp est en fait il
est plus facile de 2
vingt deux clics et j'aime ou j'aime pas
il est même plus facile de hays passe
quand même beaucoup de haine dans les
réseaux sociaux il est plus facile de
haïr que de réfléchir mais quand je
discute avec des gens dans la rue avec
des amis moi j'ai pas l'impression que
les gens réagissent comme ils le font
sur les réseaux sociaux
autrement dit quand vous êtes
physiquement devant quelqu'un
la nuance revient quand vous êtes devant
un écran souk et de limite à votre
propre enthousiasme pour telle ou telle
idée
ça peut en effet se radicaliser beaucoup
plus rapidement moi je me suis fait
insulter sur les réseaux sociaux par des
gens que j'ai fini par rencontrer et
c'était absolument charmant c'est
rassurant alors finalement les
comportements sociaux ou à travers les
écrans diffère de la vie classique
ça veut dire que c'est rassurant dans le
sens que ça montre que nous sommes des
animaux sociaux
nous avons besoin de rencontrer des gens
pour discuter pour apprendre pour se
disputer aussi mais c'est la rencontre
physique qui est la grande
caractéristique du lien social et les
réseaux dits sociaux ne font pas ce
travail social puisque justement et
porte à la radicalisation des positions
si je veux je suis la crise ducobu dont
on n'arrive pas trop par angers ça
puisque par définition il ya une
dissension sociale
comment est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
la force d'être distant socialement
compère de l'alliance
moi je préférerais qu'on parle de
distanciation physique plutôt que de
distanciation sociale parce que
finalement c'est l'espace qui est
concerné on a tout à fait le droit de
discuter à distance
donc on peut avoir une vie sociale tout
un tas tout en étant distant
physiquement mais en effet le
confinement évidemment pour tout ce qu
on discute là pour la nuance c'est sans
doute pas très favorable swann de la
disparition de la nuance en apparence en
tout cas dans nos sociétés
mais lille est à mon avis une crise du
langage c'est à dire que on parle
beaucoup avec des slogans
or clamé un slogan et réfléchir sont
deux choses complètement différentes et
donc je pense que et j'aimerais bien
citer proust si vous permettez proust a
écrit quelque part cette phrase
absolument génial edit j'ai toujours
honoré ceux qui défendent la grammaire
et la logique on se rend compte
cinquante ans après qu'ils ont conjuré
de grand père est là et je pense que
nous animons langage par le fait que les
phrases sont courtes que l'argumentation
disparaît qu'on provoque des clashs
plutôt qu' on ne laisse place à la
nuance justement et que la vérité sans
doute n'est pas simple à dire je crois
pas qu'ils vérité simple et donc la
vérité suppose pour être dit de façon
juste que les propos qui prétendent la
nommait soigne on s'est même si elle est
créditée radicale même une vérité
radical doit être dite façon nuancée
ce qui est nouveau et c'est peut-être
même une mutation anthropologique de
premier ordre
c'est que autrefois que l'information
c'était une doré extrêmement rare les
gens manquaient tout le temps
l'information et donc la formation été
précieuse aujourd'hui on est bombardé
d'informations et je pense que notre
cerveau ne peut pas tout les jeunes et
en même temps et donc doit pratiquer
l'absence de nuances pour décider de ce
à quoi il va accorder du crédit ce qui
va rejeter d'un revers de main parce que
notre cerveau n'est pas accabler pour
gérer en même temps autant de
l'information différente et je pense
qu'en effet l'excès d'information limite
notre capacité à la traiter de façon
nuancée
parfois je me rends compte que je vous
laisse piéger
vous êtes en train d'attendre un bus ou
un métro il vous regardez votre
téléphone et c'est comme si votre
sabbouri clamait
d'être constamment emporté dans un
délire dont vous voyez bien que c'est un
délire mais qui a un pouvoir entraînant
qui finit par vous vous captiver quoi et
donc c'est bien de faire l'éloge de la
nuance c'est bien de constater qu'elle
nous manque mais c'est bien aussi
d'apprendre à l'est mais le salut ça
consisterait à faire en sorte que les
gens modérés s'engage dans les débats
sans modération
sans modération il faut que la
modération s'exprime de façon immodéré
parce que sinon c'est ceux qui ont les
discours polarisant tranchées qui vont
s'imposer et ça empêcherait le débat un
débat c'est tout le contraire d'une
guerre de tranchées
on est en train de se parler on va faire
une vidéo il va diffuser sur brut on
puisse ou cette vidéo il va voir plein
de commentaires assez peu de lancers
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire aux
personnes qui ont commandé cette vidéo
écoutez je dirais aux personnes qui vont
commenter cette vidéo que je les
remercie d'avoir pris le temps de
regarder la vidéo en question et je leur
signale à l'avant ce que je ne répondrai
qu'aux commentaires qui font plus de dix
lignes
la nuance est une affaire de taille
la nuance a besoin de longues heures en
effet de temps ce qui ne veut pas dire
que les textes longs serait toujours
sans nuance oui comme je suis danser